welcome back uh now i'm gonna do a bit
of a review of of everything we've
learned so far about maybe even
trigonometry and trig identities and
then we'll see if we can come up with uh
maybe use what we already know to come
up with a couple more uh trig identities
so you know we know that you know from
sohcahtoa we know that sine
sine of theta
is equal to
the opposite
over the hypotenuse right like if we
were to draw a triangle here
if i were to draw a triangle here
whoops how come oh there you go look at
that
okay so this is theta
this is the opposite this is the
adjacent this is hypotenuse right
then sine of theta is equal to opposite
over hypotenuse cosine of theta this is
basic review hopefully at this point is
the adjacent over the hypotenuse
the tangent of theta
is equal to the opposite over the
adjacent which is also equal to the sine
of theta
over the cosine of theta we showed this
in a couple of videos ago
and then these are kind of almost
definitional but
the
cosecant
the cosecant
of theta
is equal to the hypotenuse over the uh
over the opposite which is the same
thing as one over sine of theta and you
can just memorize this
i mean i i i find it silly that there is
such a thing as cosec i guess it's just
for convenience because you know
everyone knows it's just 1 over sine of
theta and same thing for secant
secant
theta it's really for convenience
instead of having to say you know in the
case of secant oh that's one you know
if you end up with the equation one over
cosine of theta you can say oh that's
just the secant of theta
i think it actually has some obvious
properties and if you were to draw a
unit circle and all that too but uh
anyway so that's equal to
the hypotenuse over the adjacent which
is equal to one over cosine of theta
and then of course cotton cotangent of
theta is equal to the adjacent over the
opposite which is equal to
one over
tan
theta and of course that's also equal to
cosine of theta
over sine theta right it's just the
opposite of of the tangent of theta
right or that's that's the same thing as
that's the same thing as what that's the
same thing as the
the
secant no no no it's the same thing as
cosecant of
let me make sure i get this right it's
the same thing
as
the
i just want to get the inverses well
let's prove it what it is actually i
always confuse myself so
this this is the same thing as
1 over
the the
secant of theta
over
1 over the cosecant of theta right
secant of theta cosecant theta and then
that equals
that equals the cosecant of theta
over the secant of theta
i wouldn't waste your time memorizing so
we know that cotangent of theta is equal
to one over tangent theta is equal to
the cosine over the sine and it also
equals the cosecant over the secant and
i wouldn't worry about really memorizing
this you could derive it if you had to
as you could tell i i really didn't have
this memorized either and we also
learned in in previous uh videos
that the sine squared
theta plus the cosine
squared of theta is equal to one that
just comes from the pythagorean theorem
and then if you play around with this a
little bit you'd also get that
the tangent
squared theta plus 1 is equal to the
secant
secant squared theta you actually go
from here to here if you just divide
both sides of this equation by uh cosine
squared so we know that and then if you
if
if you if you've watched the last two
proof videos i made we also know that
the sine
of let's say a plus b
is equal to
the sine of
a
times
times the cosine of b
plus
let me erase some of this because i
don't think that that is an important
trig identity you can derive it on your
own i just wanted to show you that
you could figure it out
i'm using too much space
okay now i have space
let me find that blue color i was using
and make sure my pen is small okay so
that's the sine of a times the cosine of
b plus the sine of b
times the cosine of a
and you might want to just memorize it
this actually becomes really useful when
you actually start doing a calculus
because you have to solve derivatives
and integrals that you might have to
know the identity and it's not that hard
to memorize right it's it's the sine of
one of them times the cosine of one of
them plus the other way around that's
all this is and then we also learned
that the cosine
of a plus b
is the cosine of both of them
minus the sine of both of them so that
is equal to the cosine of a
times the cosine of b
and we i prove this in another video
hopefully do to your satisfaction
minus
the sine
of a
times the sine of b
that's these these are pretty useful
because from these we can we can come up
with uh with a bunch of other trig
identities for example what is the sine
of 2a
the sine
well that's just the same thing as the
sine of a plus a
sine of a plus a and if we use this trig
identity up here that is equal to
sine
of a
cosine
plus the sine
of a cosine of a right i just used this
sine of a plus b identity up here and i
just pulled a and b are both a
and what does this equal well this is
two terms that are just both sine of a
cosine of a so that just equals
sine of a
cosine of a so we now
have derived another trigonometric
identity that might be in the inside
cover of your of your of your trig or
actually your calculus book so let me
let me i mean all of these actually i i
could draw square around all of them but
let's do another one let's let's figure
out it's actually once you once you have
a bit of a a library of trig identities
you can really just keep playing around
and seeing what else you can uh and i
encourage you to do so and you can you'd
be amazed how many other trig identities
you could come up with
for example let's do cosine of 2a
cosine of 2a
is equal to
cosine
of a
plus a
right
and cosine of a plus a what did we say
it's the cosine of both of the terms
times
each other minus the sine of both the
terms so that equals
cosine
of a
cosine of a right cosine of a times
cosine of a minus
sine of a sine of a we we saw this
identity was the you know the cosine of
a plus b identity
minus sine of a so what is this this is
equal to
cosine
squared a
minus
sine
squared a
that's interesting i mean i could i know
we could play around this is interesting
right because this is this is the form a
squared minus b squared right so that's
also the same thing as a plus b times a
minus b so that's the same thing as
cosine
of a plus sine of a
times
cosine
of a minus sine of a i don't know this
isn't really a trigonometry but you know
i'm just showing you could you could
play with things the cosine of 2a is
equal to cosine of a plus sine of a
times cosine of a minus sine of a so the
the sum of of
you know the cosine of sine of a and
that times the difference that's just
interesting i'm just showing you that
that what's fun about trigonometry you
can kind of keep playing around with it
and actually that's probably that is how
all of the trig identities were
discovered
so let's say that we have you know we
want to figure out what
cosine
of let's say
negative a is
let me draw a right triangle
whoops that's almost a right triangle
and let's say this angle is a right
so negative a
unit circle would look something like
this right
negative a so cosine of
a if we say that this side is the
adjacent
side this is a hypotenuse this would
still be the hypotenuse right
and this is the opposite this is the
negative opposite
so
cosine of minus a is equal to what
this is minus a so it's the adjacent
over the hypotenuse so it equals the
adjacent
over the hypotenuse which we just say is
h but that's the same thing as cosine of
a right
because cosine of a is also the adjacent
over the i over the hypotenuse adjacent
over hypotenuse
oh i'm almost out of time let me switch
to a new video